hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 1916 Reister
Mint in New York capablanca is seven in
seven and this is a game right after the
previous one that we've shown a couple
Blancas faces Albert Hearts he's a very
strong American chess master he was US
Champion well a few years back and he's
he's also very well known for
controlling the ajeeb the the chess
playing automaton as there were several
of them throughout chess history so this
is a jeep he was controlling this well
this automaton and it's it's a wonderful
game in those days I mean over a hundred
years ago you didn't have an engine so
when you had a dispute someone said this
line was better other person said that
line was better so I mean who gonna
listen to Alaska says this couple Blanca
says this let's say tar says that I mean
both of them are very strong it's hard
to agree with someone and here is one
such case where Albert Hodge uses one
such line against Capablanca that are
used in the 1914 tournaments of son
Peter Berg Tara defeated also Bernstein
with the black pieces and he almost
defeated Emanuele ask her the game was
drawn but he had an excellent game with
the black pieces and the Capablanca
published a note about this this exact
line that star effused and he said that
white did not play that game correctly
and here you'll see how cup of cup of
Montcalm uses this line against Albert
Hearts but we're gonna return to that a
bit more during the game so Capablanca
opens with E 4 we have E 5 9 2 3
sorry Knight f3 knight c6 this is a bit
too high up so I don't see the board and
Bishop to b5 the rule opus is on the
board a 6 more fees defense Bishop to a4
knife to f6 and now we have castles by
kappa blanka
going after this very nice line Knight
captures on e4
we have d4 and now b5 Bishop to b3 we
have d5 now and D captures sorry D Phi D
5 by black and D characters on e5 of
course and Bishop to e6 and this is
where the game took a different turn in
Bernstein versus Tartars game
Knight B to d2 was played in that game
but here
Blanka continues in a different fashion
here kappa blanka goes with c3 it's the
exact same move emmanuel a square played
against Irish in the 1914 tournament oh
son Peter Berg and the game continues in
the same fashion Bishop to e7 Knight B
to d2 and now comes now comes Knights to
c5 and here we have Bishop - C - of
course getting the better part of the
wake of Blanca is reluctant to part with
the Bishop prepare we have d4 by black
and Knight to e4 and this is a work of a
Blanca says that white has the advantage
if white plays Knight to e4 and that
black shouldn't be able to play this for
a win but let's see a how kappa blanka
played this first we have d captures on
c3 by black couple blanca plays Knight
captures on c5 with Bishop captures on
c5 and now comes the bishop to e4 you
have to do something about this pin and
also the knight is under attack on c6 so
what do you do here you have to block
the attack against the night you can't
move the knight so you can block with
the Queen or you can block with the
bishop the problem with blocking with
the bishop for example Bishop to d7 is
that white wins the game on the spot but
it's it's such a nice tactic that I even
though the line never happened I have
paused the video here and try to find
the winning move for white in this
position it's just a very nice idea for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
solver of tactics that never happened
across the board and photos if you just
want to enjoy the show you have to
notice that the Bishop on c5 is
unguarded so the idea is Queens that's
v5r e maneuvering the Queen's to d5
while attacking the bishop and also
you're interested in that h5 square but
all will be revealed much up to b6 or
Bishop to e7 doesn't really matter as
the idea is quite similar if the bishop
to e7 then comes rook to d1 you prevent
black from castling because if black
castles then of course you lose the
bishop on d7 and now after black makes a
move any move pretty much you will just
play east 6 and you win if you capture
with the bishop then Queen captures and
c6 would check and of course if you
capture with the pond then Queen to h5
check will force you to go either King
to f8
which is not all that great because now
just a bunch of captures on c6 when the
piece you will not be able to recapture
because of well you lose the Queen and
on the other hand after Queen to h5
check you can go g6 but now just Bishop
captures and if you capture black loses
the rook if you go here then it's just
Bishop h6 check King g8 and Bishop to f7
a very nice Bishop checkmate from from
White's perspective so already it's only
move 14 but there is poison in the
position so Queen to d7 you have to
defend the knife this way capablanca
goes B captures and c3 takes away these
very nice two squares from Hearts night
and also prepares this d4 as an output
for the night
after we have worked the d8 now
threatening to capture the Queen on d1
and only now this kappa blanka exchange
with Queen captures on d7 Bishop
captures on d7 and now rook to d1 again
with some pressure not allowing black to
castle but here black panicked a little
bit it's it's not like black can't
castle it seems like there is this trick
of the root cap for some b7 root captors
and here winning a piece but there
really isn't because well you still
haven't developed your Dorf score
there's a pin you were getting
checkmated here
so if black one or two black could have
castles here what he first he went night
to b8 re maneuvering the night but this
is not one of those cases where a move
would the knight back is the strongest
move but okay now the d4 square is no
longer attacked twice so Knights the d4
with Bishop but back to e7 by black and
now Bishop to e3 by Capablanca finally
hearts castles and rook to d2 now
Capablanca is ready to double up rooks
on the D file
what does it black do first c5 a nice
expansion on the Queen side we have
Knight back to be three with a double
attack against this point and now you
could push c4 but then you again give up
the d4 square for whites night so rook
the c8 defending the pawn this way but
you are you know for losing control of
the D file and kappa blanka takes
advantage of this rook a to D one
doubles up rooks on the D file and now
Capablanca is the you know
the true owner of the d-file Bishop to
g4 as the bishop was attacked the threat
was rook captures Bishop so Bishop to g4
attacks the rockin d1 f3 defending and
only now Bishop to e6 and
capablanca now pushes f4 with ideas of
closing this bishops diagonal with f5 f5
where you will not be able to go back
you will have to give up the bishop
repair and that will be great advantage
for capablanca so g6 not allowing a five
but capablanca once again prepares it
with h3 now preparing g4 and f5 so black
goes c4 expanding yet further on the
Queen set but again giving up the d4
square to capablanca Snite so Knights
the d4 and only now Bishop to c5 now
you're not able to capture of course
here because Bishop captures an e3 comes
with check so here kappa blanka first
takes care of that King to f2 now if the
bishop captures you will be able to
capture with the King and black now
doesn't want his Bishop captures so
Bishop back to d7 and now we reach a
position we're going back with the night
and I move with the knight back is in
fact the strongest move and Capablanca
plays it Knights the c2 and fefe he
forces a trait of dark square Bishop
which will result in him improving the
position of his scheme you have to
capture you don't have the option of
going back because just rook captures
Bishop on d7 so Bishop captures on e3
with Czech king captures the knight
wants to come to d4 either way and now
comes Bishop to c6 offering a trade
bishops and now rook the d6 putting huge
pressure on on black 6 Frank the bishop
is now threatened if the knight or burn
bishop moves the a6 pawn will be under
attack and well black will just keep
white will just keep on improving the
position with rook to c7 with ideas of
the other group coming to see it but
this rook has plans of going to a7 we
have Knights to be for now again with a
triple attack against the bishop here
forcing the trade on e4 but what
Capablanca really wants to do is grab a
hold of the d5 square for his Knight and
then grab a hold of this f6 square for
his Knight and that is
well then then you really do have a
monster night so Bishop captures only
four with King captures on e4 you can
see that even though the material on the
board is equal everything perfectly
equal material wise couple Blanca King a
powerful King and black scheme not
really doing all that much just yet so
first a five by Black Knight to d5 you
cannot prevent the knight from coming to
d5 and even though a white no longer
controls the d7 squared twice you can't
oppose white rook because just Knight of
six check wins the game the nicely
connects with the rook and it's winning
for white so after Knight to d5 we have
looked a seven s planned trying to well
maybe would be four you can play a
capture some before and then open up the
a file but also trying to activate
black's knight this way because this
night is on be eight ever since black
panicked in the hand in the opening
where he just could have castle but he
decided maybe it's a bit too dangerous
but Capablanca goes a three takes care
of the b4 idea and now comes Knight to a
six by black rook the c6 now this is
just a beautiful move the knight and a
six seems to be doing it seems to be
doing something but not really
couple of angle goes rook to c6 and he
just takes away all the squares from the
Black Knight this is taken now the rook
controls both c5 and C seven tonight
also helps out with the control of the
c7 square and now you can just go back
with the knight which doesn't really do
anything or you can try what black
played in the game black played rook to
b8 now really hoping to push some b4
ideas but Capablanca just goes Knight to
f6 check we have king to g7 and now rook
B to d6 and here the knight is trapped
there's no going back with the night
this is taken this is taken the only
square available for the night is c7 but
night to c7 loses very quickly I'm sure
all of you see it without even pausing
the video so I'm just gonna show it you
just attack the knight now there's a
double attack on the night you cannot
move the knight because of rook captures
rook and after black defends it now I
just capture the night rook captures
captures captures captures and now of
course Knight the e8 check nicely
connects black has to move
and pal Knight captures leaves white up
a piece with a completely winning
endgame and due to the couple mangas
powerful position of the king
no be for tricks are even possible in
the position so black realizes that
there is no saving the knight black just
plays be for hopes to create at least
some counter play but capablanca is not
gonna be fooled easily he just plays
eight capture some before the the knight
isn't really going anywhere eight
capture some before and only now this
capablanca captured a piece route
captures on a six we have looked the c7
of course not interested in trading
material but now just look a to be six
opposing the rope here and preparing to
capture here and it was in this position
on move forty that American chess master
Albert Hodge resigned the game what if
you resign while he's down a full piece
and he can either just move the rook or
and lose the before pawn which is
basically his only source of counter
play even though it's not all that
impressive or he can play rook captures
and after captures you still you're
still gonna lose the point if you play
something like B 3 again 98 check or
again nicely connects you're gonna lose
the rook and the game chef
Hodge didn't wait for any of this after
couple Blancas rook a to b6 he resigned
the game and capablanca is now eight in
eight so eight wins in a row which is
just you know impressive but it is what
we expect from jose role as he is you
know the the cuban legend but yeah
that's the game i do hope you enjoyed it
and that you've learned something from
this I really have it's just a wonderful
game really educational and also it's
very very nice hot cup of ok it doesn't
really prove anything
I'm the the dispute was probably still
going on Tosh was saying no the line was
better for black cover Lanka said the
line was better for white and Alka
Blanca defeats Albert hearts with this
exact same line that towers defeated
Austin Bernstein and almost defeated
Emmanuel Lasker
but you know at least the dispute is
still going on and there's you know
something going on in the chess world
which is always great but yeah once
again does the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Karen G
since William Holford Hamid alkyd
Mitchell young and Martin Cole for a
contribution to my channel thank you
laterally
Shadid as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content
continuing the kappa blanka saga
checking up on your suggestions and we
are preparing for the Branca Jazz
Festival and I will most likely tomorrow
you know treat you with with the story
of the couch the one behind me yeah I
think you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day